un automóvil que sale del hospital San
Rafael en Milán y escenas de
espectadores a bordo el cadáver de la
figura central de la derecha italiana
Silvio berlusconi Seguidores del partido
político fundado por berlusconi Forza
Italia despiden a su líder vine aquí Tan
pronto escuché las noticias me parecía
imprescindible venir a rendir un
homenaje a nuestro presidente que
siempre ha sido una parte importante de
nuestras vidas
la primera ministra Georgia meloni
también de derechas reconoció el legado
de quien fue cuatro veces Primer
Ministro hulu en Italia
aprendió a no aceptar los límites
impuestos por otros aprendió a no
Rendirse Adiós Silvio
desde Bruselas también hubo
pronunciamiento verlos Connie lidero
Italia durante la peor crisis económica
de la eurozona obviamente enviamos
nuestras condolencias a la familia de y
al pueblo italiano en general
por su parte el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin enemistado con la Unión Europea lo
calificó como un querido y sabio amigo
las izquierdas recordaron los escándalos
sexuales y de corrupción de berlusconi
como el ex líder de podemos en España la
propia repugnancia de un personaje
corrupto un violador un
representante de la banalización de la
política es un adelantado a su tiempo
una visión contraria a la derecha
española que lamentó la muerte